good evening I'm Matthew Spalding I'm
associate vice president in Dean for
Hillsdale College here in Washington DC
welcome to the Allen P Kirby Center for
Constitutional studies and citizenship
where we often talk about constitutional
studies but also like to talk about
citizenship and those things that are
necessary for citizenship and for the
right type of education about the
liberal arts which is our topic this
evening in particular it's about the art
of words an evening book discussion on
classical education and children's books
but of course we're very happy to also
have a book launch although this is only
the DC book launch for this wonderful
new book mr. means mildly amusing
mythical amaz Matthew Mian the book says
if you look in the back is a poet
scholar teacher and musician he's PhD
from the University of Dallas he is a
teacher at the high school in Potomac
Maryland and he is also there were some
teaching fellow here at Hillsdale
College the Kirby Center where he
teaches literature I am Shannon from his
wife Molly lead also sings in the shower
musician part John Miller on the other
hand when we had this discussion we want
to talk about the book and we also
wanted to get a lot more out of Matt
because he has a lot more to tell us and
teach us we have the idea that we should
have him interviewed and that this would
be more interesting and we thought John
would be the perfect person John runs
the DAO journalism Center at Hillsdale
College and teaches about journalism
he's also a fellow does a lot of work
with National Review where in particular
he also runs two podcasts the book
monger and the great books both which
are excellent but he thinks a lot about
books and interviews authors about
books so we thought this would be a
perfect occasion to have that
conversation so again welcome the walk
of the book is wonderful I greatly
endorse it and please enjoy the evening
John floors yours thank you Matt
Spaulding hello
welcome everybody can hear us okay all
right
so my goal tonight is for all of you to
have a mildly amusing evening with us
now let's talk about your book
graduations on the publication of it
authors when they write books are often
advised to have an elevator pitch right
we hear we hear this in Hollywood also
but needs an elevator pitch so that on
on the occasion of your getting stuck in
an elevator and you have 30 seconds with
a book elevator with a book editor or a
movie producer and you've got 30 seconds
to get this person's attention what do
you say about your book
what is your elevator pitch for mr.
Meehan's mildly amusing mythical mammals
yeah over promise and under deliver or
under deliver an open promise yeah it's
a book about mythical mammals it's an
alphabet one poem for each letter of the
alphabet and it's a journey of two of
them the blog this guy and the dahle
that guide who go on a little journey of
friendship and they learn a lot about
how to master their emotions right and
how to essentially encounter
difficulties and have a happy and joyful
life that's the sort of meta narrative
of the whole thing but the other part of
the pitch is it's a family book not just
a kids book that is it's something that
adults can get a lot out of adolescence
and teenagers can get a lot out of
children and the middle grades and even
the littles because there's alphabets
there's rhyme and fun fuzzy little
mammals and it's something that for the
whole family you can engage at whatever
level and throughout your life hopefully
you can come to edit as a child you can
come at as an dad
lesson and you can come at it again and
again as an adult it's a swimming pool
there's a shallow end and there's a deep
end excellence is that a good elevator
pitch should we continue good so so so
let's go on I want to ask what the title
mister means mildly amusing mythical
mammals so you like alliteration
yes guilty as charged I was Matthew Mian
right so so so blame my parents so so
let's unpack the title a little bit mild
mildly amusing I mean that's that's an
under selling yeah of the of the book I
think yeah I look mr. means mildly
amusing mythical mammals to be mildly
amusing and have that in the middle
mildness is actually something that the
poetic arts teach people right that how
do you communicate something in a way
that doesn't require force manipulation
pushiness violence sometimes look
sometimes you have to be violent right
there's war and there's serious things
but there's a whole other realm of peace
that involves the arts of rhetoric and
poetry and image and communication so I
wanted to focus on mildly because I
don't think I'm saying anything that's
surprising here in this room no one's
gonna be shocked to find out we are sort
of degrading ourselves into a harsh age
that gets pretty you know pushy and
violent in our speech right well look
I'm not for safe spaces but I am for
artful speech that actually persuades
people so I wanted mildness because I
think that's something that the poetic
arts teach and amusing as in the middle
of the the title in the idea of to be
amusing is fun but it's also a pun on
musing inspiration right and so you you
you want to something that's both
delightful and instructive right
something that's fun and goofy and you
know not too painful
but then has a much higher register
because it's channeling things that are
in essence divine so do you actually
invoke the muses at the start of the
book I guess you kind of do with the
title so subliminally
do you have a deliberative voguing of
the muses like you're an epic poet right
in the front of this thing there is a
kind of very subtle one in if you the
first image that you encounter in the
entire book is a little caduceus what is
a caduceus visual aids are very helpful
I've learned that and you mean the Pat
the patter and a turn right here on the
end and it's winds up being the second
thing you see as well and it's a little
glyph of an image of Matthew 10:16
behold I send you out as sheep among the
wolves be wise as serpents innocent as
doves
that is a very low-grade subtle
reference to the source of inspiration
which is God right and yes beyond that -
there's lots of inspiration I you know I
try to make allusions to poets and all
the people that helped inspire this book
but there is a kind of very serious call
for divine aid that starts the book I'm
impressed you've thought really hard
about what you're putting into this book
it sounds like share with us a little
piece of the book if you will it's it's
it's full of poetry it's got these great
pictures we're not gonna do a whole
whole reading for you but can you share
a piece of the book with us give us a
read read a portion you know a poem made
sure yeah I can try and recite one or
you have a memorized sure some of them I
mean and some of them I'm still working
on them but we'll pick a good one well I
mean it might be good to start simple
and just do the the dahle which is he's
right there he's the lead character it's
this one yeah and he has necktie ears
because if you don't know that's a
symbol of the Western tradition if you
want to really nerd out but that's
another story maybe and they're yellow
and blue the sign of cheerfulness and
the sign of sorrow and sadness
so already he's got a little bit of a
struggle on his hand
alright so the dahle to me looks like a
dog yes with a with a very different and
odd
okay every one of the mammals except for
one are actually add mixtures of
different kinds of creatures because
this is clearly a hippo and a Blowfish
and a Blowfish it's like Thanksgiving
and a bumblebee or a little gnat he's
got the little wings yes that's the blog
the blog yeah and he's right little
monitor lizard feet and okay each of
them are mixed together which is what
one of the things poetry does it's it's
a it's a mixing and a remix and new and
these creatures never have been seen in
the wild not that I know of all right CY
number one you want to tell us about the
Dahle yes sight the devil so this is so
this is so the book goes through the
ABCs and so d is for Dahle Rabia so and
this is the poem for the letter D that's
right okay no you go first the ABCs are
kind of introduction and then you meet
our hero the Dahle of the letter D
creature so if I screw it up this will
be no one will not arm it unless they're
reading along yeah among the pelting
drops of rain the Dahle can be seen
again the rocks the trees they know him
well where he'll show no one can tell
for though the forests soaked and socked
the Dahle skirts each drop that's
plucked but if you are one keen of eye
who sits and Stoops and storms you'll
spy the dodgy dolly dancing dry that's
it very nice
all right so what does all that mean in
one sense not much he's a creature he's
it's a light poem right there's light
verse he's a little creature who likes
to dodge the rain when he starts out you
find him laughing and dodging raindrops
no problem
the very next poem he meets the evil and
the evil actually tempts him into
sitting down and having a long chat with
evil we're all evil as Evo ell that's in
the book right okay the evil and he has
a long conversation and in that
conversation he hears all of the saddest
kinds of things that you could possibly
imagine and he by stopping he's rained
on because there is a rain storm but
he's also even cried on the tears of the
evil who is the saddest creature and so
the rest of the book is the dahle trying
to recover from meeting the evil and
hearing the most sort of in one sense
the biggest lies you could imagine that
everything is fundamentally sad right
that the whole world is tragedy right
bereft of comedy and the evil actually
isn't blind ape he's a he's a he's a
cave-dwelling troglodytic ape that's a
word you can look up in the glossary in
the book he's a troglodyte
he's a cave dweller no eat no eyes and
so he he claims he can see the whole
world but in realities or finally blind
I know what a troglodyte is because I
played Dungeons and Dragons I don't I do
not need to look up that word but but
you do have you do have a whole glossary
in the back of this book and it takes up
I want to say about a third of the book
even more than forth less than third is
is okay so so why so much glossary why
so many hard words yeah Mr Mian that's
right no that's right so the reason
being I want people to love words and I
want people to learn how
express themselves and there was
actually a very powerful phenomenon in
pedagogy and education for a while that
said hey keep things stupid and
thematically simple like just keep it
simple stupid for everybody and don't
give children all of the sort of rolling
out the toolkit of language for ideas
but in reality I'm with you know Richard
Weaver and a thousand others who say the
the tools of civilization and the tools
not just of the exterior civilization
but civilization of the soul like how do
you actually govern yourself requires
infinite numbers of instruments and
those instruments are represented by
words so I want children adults I want
people to engage words and grow their
vocabulary because it's like Orwell said
right if you can remove the words you
can essentially erase the memory out of
a culture so I want people to have the
gift of words so this is a balancing act
though isn't it because I know as a
journalist you never want to use a
really hard where you don't alienate
your audience right and and and one of
the one of the goals and journalism is
is to meet your readers where they're at
on the one hand on the other hand there
are times when maybe you do need to use
a little tougher word or or or it's not
really the fault of the writer that you
don't understand it maybe it's the fault
of the reader and the reader oughta look
up something so you're you're you're
you're trying to inspire people to what
expand vocabularies and study for the
SAT with your book there's definitely
that yeah I mean there is that aspect
actually I want it to be useful right
there's a there's a kind of
misperception of the liberal arts today
that it has to be exquisitely an
exclusively useless like actually that's
part of it it is just Noble and a
glorious thing for free people to do so
a beautiful elegant word that you might
not know is a good thing to learn but
it's also I would like people to become
educated and aid them so yes SAT
builders you've been but on the higher
level you know in one sense journalists
don't have the advantage of a bunch of
gorgeous pictures rhyme poetry fancy I
can make it easy because you have to
deal with a word but you kind of want to
know what it means because
as you're engaged in a free and
delightful exercise so you know the old
joke never use a $10 word when a $1 word
will do well yeah but where do you learn
those $10 words we're getting to a point
now where no one knows that $10 worked
right everyone just has $1 bills and
they can't use the perfect word when you
have to or you really should in one of
my courses at Hillsdale College I have
students read some Samuel Johnson and
they read an essay from the Rambler that
he wrote in the 1750s or something like
that and it is on this very question
about do you want to speak to your
audience and language it will understand
or when do you challenge and how is it
writer do you do you make these
decisions and I was reminded of that
when I was looking through your glossary
because you quote Samuel Johnson like
crazy right in the glossary hundred
percent yeah use the two dictionaries
for it and and I also add my own glosses
and stories and poems and little
treasures and interpretive aids for the
poems and there's a like I said there's
a very there's a lot of depth you can go
and go full nerd if you want if you love
the liberal arts at nerd levels you can
do it but I use dr. Johnson's dictionary
which is the first major dictionary of
the english-speaking you know the
Anglophone world and then I use
Webster's dictionary which is the great
first great American dictionary so I try
to introduce people to the tradition of
the Anglophone world our language which
is an enormous treasure and that's one
of the things I start the book with too
is we more or less start at Eton and at
Oxford which are I think sort of
primordial you know Lazarus pits for her
you know where our language comes from
and our culture and ideas because I want
that so normally the glossary is like
the boring part of the book that nobody
wants to bother with but I think it's
maybe the best part of this blog I
really enjoyed reading is funny and
you're playing word games and and and
hiding meanings and
and so forth that's right right Thank
You Ivan that's your you may be the
fifth or sixth person in the world to
have read through the whole questions
yeah but but the glossary is written as
a way to look up words that are in the
poems but it also if you want you know
high level you know nerd work if you
want to just read through it I've
written it sort of like a like the book
of Proverbs is written you know like
just random things that seem
disconnected but if you just hang with
it you actually start to see patterns
and you're actually led somewhere even
though the one's about like reaching
into a wall and getting bit by snake and
the other ones about you know having a
fractious wife and you want to live on
the roof instead of be with her my
wife's wonderful so don't worry
but like all these disconnected things
that actually when you put them together
are painting a picture of the whole I
try to give an image of the Western
tradition the ars rhetorica ARS Poetica
and Christian humanism and what it is to
be a human being in community and in a
self-governing environment which is you
know so there are illustrations in the
glossary but but really the glossary is
very texty compared to the rest of the
book and in fact these these beautiful
illnesses are with with the poetry at
the front when you're telling the actual
story of of the book so tell us a little
bit about these paintings you don't have
you have an illustrator who's not you
you did the word someone else okay so so
who is who is he and and and how did you
guys conspire John Paul II was the head
of the art department at the hight
school and you know which is where you
teach where I teach in the daytime Bay
yeah I still teach there and he and I
would sit for lunch and talk about
Holbein and you know Christian humanism
and Homer and William Carlos wings we
just had these awesome lunches because
don't we all have these conversations on
our lunch breaks come work with me the
no but we would talk about these things
and we also talked about how the arts
like there there are there are
weaknesses there are holes in these sort
of put it this way team good guy I
referred a team good guy in team
guy I'm not going to tell you which one
you are but but but there's a sort of
like people who really want the good
they tend to be fighting with just their
left arm or right arm and the arts are
this whole avenue of goodness that
people don't use very well so we talked
about a love this for a long time and
decided like yeah let's collaborate
let's do this he wound up leaving I want
him to be the illustrator before he
wound up leaving he left and became
apprentice under Paul in Britain up in
New Hampshire who's you can trace his
line all the way through the Boston
school you know cold aborts in Paris all
the way back direct line to the
workshops of Florence to Raphael's
workshop and so he's a realist
impressionist you know rock star master
and that's his word no but so he and I
decided we were gonna do this together
and we spend a whole year doing
practices we did political cartoons to
see if we could get my mind and his
paintbrush merged together and it
actually took a long time to get that
and so we made now we've got 26 oil
paintings one for each letter of the
alphabet and a bunch of pen and ink
letter blocks and you know each painting
is chocked full of you know a delightful
colors beautiful he's a master of light
and dark that's what his real strength
is so there's all this incredible
luminosity in the paintings but it's
also chocked full of symbolism of the
Western tradition too so so give an
example of what you mean take pick one
of these pictures here and tell us what
okay and this one the blood is because
what is what is the symbolism I'm seeing
I'm seeing The Tortoise and the hare
I don't know what else am I supposed to
see yeah so this is this is Christchurch
Mehta walk and this is in the back and
okay this is Oxford Christchurch college
and it's this is you know one of the
birthplaces of the English language and
and the Arts and Letters of the
english-speaking world this is actually
Peter Tenniel's original illustration
quoted from Lewis Carroll and then
obviously I Aesop's fables so the the
blog the bumbling by as slow as the slug
is the Tobias creature known as the
he plots a humourist pesos low in fact
that he came in third place against the
tortoise in the air who had the finish
line stood and stared at this blah
Bueller jolly gelatinous jug ru ru died
his body he loved are you quoting your
own poem again guilty okay so you're the
but the but didn't we and we are selling
it after aren't we I hope yeah I think
we're okay but the the blood he is the
sort of Sancho Panza of the whole thing
he's the buoyant cheerful Sun colored
Sun shaped big fat buoyant guy and he is
what I think poetry is which is a kind
of combination of very heavy things and
this is a very heavy fat mammal right
but done in a winsome and light way
right you can talk about serious
questions of like Pride and tyranny and
kingship and you can do it in a nice ops
fable about a stork and some frogs right
so you can teach really heavy stuff
through very light some stuff the blood
floats sort of above Aesop's fables like
mere lesson just the moral right because
whimsy and fantasy and the formation the
imagination is more than that right and
in the background to is the transcendent
right Christ's Church college right sort
of these sorts of higher philosophical
and theological considerations and there
is a finish line there's a Tilos there's
an end to the arts it's not aimless even
though the arts tend to go slow and take
you in a very strange and circumlocution
say so there's ya know is every kid
gonna get this absolutely no but a
teacher who wants to use this book can
open up the mysteries and secrets of the
West to their students and most people
can just enjoy a wonderful poem about a
cheerful creature that knows how to
cheer up another sad little mammal so I
love his teensy-weensy little arms you
ever yes your ex arms well well and you
have your hair ever have you ever heard
the joke why can't t-rex do push-ups
because he's extinct but he does that he
does he does it he doesn't t-rex arms so
so you're so you so your illustrator
John folly
nice last name John folly is he in
following yeah it's almost like a pen
name right but that's his real name so
so to what extent is this a
collaboration are you telling him what
to do here or you know he's executing
the painting but are you are you guys
talking about no yeah I work up a very
extensive file I show him even so when
you write a poem you actually I mean a
good poem you don't just write one poem
maybe you do this occasionally I write
zero poems but if you oftentimes you'll
write ideas for the poems almost like a
painter of a painter will write will
paint up a host of beautiful oils that
are in preparation for the big mural
right you do that with poetry too so I
shared those with him all the sort of
build-up poems that led to the final
poem so he gets the sense of what I'm
thinking and how I'm you know thinking
about this poem and then I also give him
direct visual quotes I show him pictures
of christchurch meadow walk and Oxford I
show him Peter Tenniel I we you know we
pick from a host of old steeplechase
finish line signs so we do a lot of work
together in fact there's this enormous
Google Doc like 196 pages of all of our
notes for every illustration and we go
back and forth and it's a process
so some point we're gonna have the
director's cut edition of your book
right ten times wrong that's right so so
for how long were you guys working on
this together it sounds like years years
and and you said something interesting
just a few moments ago you haven't seen
him in three and a half years and until
recently but yeah you you you you worked
remotely and he left the heights and he
was up absolutely busy starting a new
family starting his new full-time artist
business you know he's a he's a studio
artist now and he's up there and I'm
down here and I've got my kids and I've
got all my work so we for three plus
years we were just email phone email
phone every day you know just ham
get out all right now you said early on
there's a family book and you know you
don't like to refer this as a children's
book or a kids book publishing marketing
conventions almost force us to you call
it a family book what why do you why do
you like that term one family time and
families are I feel basically under
attack by you can you could point to
like evil forces of orcs you know out
there but even just the basic kind of
hubbub and hustle of life there's a
robbing of the family of it's time
together
so I wanted a book where adults could
read to children and every member of the
family would get something out of the
book as opposed to everything having to
be divided right and just things like
television are the shared activity I
wanted a book that can be shared that
was one reason just that's straight up
that's what I'd like for my family I
think it's a good thing but also part of
the poetic arts and the rhetorical arts
that would be great to recapture for
free society and free government and
Republican self-government in the United
States of America would be the habit of
knowing how to talk on a variety of
levels at one time to say to one speech
act that is communicating this to these
people that to these people this to
these people this to my child this to my
wife all at once and that's actually
something that poetry and rhetoric teach
and so I wanted to lead by example and
try to do that where a kid is going to
get a fun little fable right or in just
an amusing nonsense poem and adolescent
is going to start to see that there's
wordplay and structure and poetry and
different interesting craft going on a
little bit older than that after a
middle grade high school and above
they're gonna start to see serious
themes of psychology of politics of the
truth it sounds a little bit like a
Pixar film right the best the best Pixar
film
we'll make the littlest kids laugh
hysterically but they'll also keep the
interest of the adults with with jokes
and storylines and illusions that they
mess that the adults get yeah I used to
be part of my elevator pitch but it now
the bread birds the puppet looks like
I'm just kind of he's back I mean he was
always popular but now he's got a new
film I feel like I'm grabbing his
coattail too much man I used to say this
is like a Brad Bird film that I pitch it
to the adults but the kids will love it
and you know just why is that not a part
of your elevator pitch my goodness
that's I totally get it now okay finally
I get what you're doing poetry is is in
so many ways
dad nobody reads it anymore except in
one place and that's in children's
literature it's dr. Seuss it's it's it's
all kinds of children's lit that's
that's where it lives what does poetry
do why is it why is it such a magical
powerful medium that we should study and
and try to recover yeah that's a great
question and it's it's one of the
reasons why I decided to stake out in
children's poetry because it's a free
space where you don't have to comply
with you know oftentimes some strange
subcultural rules that poetry is not
popular anymore
there isn't popular poetry that's for
everyone at least it doesn't seem that
way to me anymore
well who can name a working poet today
right a few people can name one or two
you can't write there's not like Billy
Collins as as close as you get he's a
humorist I don't know who that is
whatever okay I mean he he goes out with
with Bill Murray now I've heard of him
right does he got a tattoo that helping
the comedian yeah okay but but yes so a
number of things one poetry you asked
earlier about the title and another word
in the title mr. Mane's mildly amusing
mythical mammals we forget we're mammals
we forget we have a body right that's
something it's actually super important
people are trying to you could see a
whole international movement if like
whoa there's a body that has
that we should follow and it's important
right but poetry speaks to the full
human being right it actually speaks to
the mind but it has rhyme and meter and
rhythm and all of these things and the
even as visual structure unlike prose
which is just whatever the page is set
usually right poetry is I can make it an
image in fact I have one of the poems is
a concrete poem it's if you shaped like
the creature just to show you the full
you know panoply of things you can do
with poetry but by actually engaging the
full body and mind of a human being
there is a certain kind of a delight I
think which is exquisite like it's
actually a very delightful thing to be
to have poetry once you get a handle on
it and figure out how to engage it which
is I try to in the glossary even give it
like help for really reengagement Ryazan
art in the family but but also it's it's
a way of that actually teaches and not
just teaches sort of the mind you know
just inside but also sort of oh I
learned something about this through my
body even which is I think one-stop-shop
that is not being utilized now you have
a mess of kids of your own I do right
yeah the me and the me and home I
determine at number that the glossary
the the mian home is crowded agreed and
one one of one of one of the
observations I made a kind of a curious
observation about children's
literature's how many great children's
our authors did not have children dr.
Seuss no kids
Margaret wise Brown author you know good
night moon like the most popular board
book ever no kids
the authors of Curious George no kids CS
Lewis author of the beloved Chronicles
of Narnia no kids I mean at a certain
point this is you know is there a
competitive advantage if you're a
children's writer and not to have kids
of your own
but but I I can also picture you
road-testing this at home and where
you're reading these poems
kids and refining them did you get any
suggestions from them oh yeah how did
that work yeah so the big worry was is
it delightful for children I mean I like
it but you know like adults like it but
is it right for kids and so I was very
important to me to see my own children
like laughs and you know fine to the
mammals amusing and the rhymes and be
able to memorize them and my kids
started memorizing them
I also took it out I've got not only do
I have a passel but a number of my
siblings have a bunch of kids too so I
wrote tested it with them I wrote tested
it with other people's families and and
so yeah I definitely that was it was
very important to me also they were
weighing in on certain things they a few
times I'd say okay read this poem
what's a mammal that I should mix into
this mammal you know soon and at one
point just randomly they picked it they
picked one I don't want to say which one
it is but they just shouted out a mammal
that they liked and I I said oh that's a
that's actually a symbol of poetic verse
in Roman literature like oh well and
then suddenly it starts to fit into all
of the wider themes - and I just laugh
is like and it's just a awesome fuzzy
animal that my kids loves they're like
sweet you know having something that's
simple and childlike but that is also
works and out of the mouths of babes a
number of times my kids made the book
way better did you ever get like Uncle
Matt your poem for the letter R just
doesn't work for me I got I don't know
if I could say that I could someone I
love to say this yeah there was the
variant kid was grounded a very first
attempt at reading one of the poems has
the I start out laughing about hard
words and how you shouldn't voiced them
on people right away and that's the Ango
which is literally they're having a
fight about whether you should say the
full name of this mammal or just call it
the Ango and the full name is the angle
grub you gunk amongst us why
yeah right like scientific names and
truth that you have to get all the truth
out right away as opposed to poetry
which says why don't you start with
things that are pleasant and delightful
and move people along in stages to the
truth right that's what myth is right
myth is an image mythical mammals its
images that lead you to the truth right
so that's like one of the thematic
introductions but it is the angle has
but little Fame because folks hate its
proper name Ango grub you Gunkel unk's
this has a ring that most fine unctuous
to hard words my my sister was like I
messed that up in front of my kids and
my kids laughed at me and I'm like good
but but I said ok I need to I learned
I'm sorry the introduction I warned
families hey there's a there are hard
words in here and it's good to flub the
funky words you can look them up in the
glossary if you want but you don't need
to know every word right just like you
don't need to know everything in life to
learn a lot and so there's actually
something I think about we don't talk
about it we talk about wisdom and the
beard and the sort of you know high and
mighty man on the mountain but there is
the laughing philosopher right
Democritus think humor that you don't
know everything the Socratic ignorance
so you can just read through something
and say well I don't know I don't know
what that word is like we'll work on it
later right and that's what I want the
book to be is you can read it again and
again and it gets deeper and deeper but
you don't get everything the first time
so you mentioned George Orwell earlier
Orwell was an advocate of what he called
anglish which is English but with an A
and he said things like we should use
common language when we're trying to
communicate things and so a word like
ornithology drove him nuts you know
which is the Latin word for what the
study of birds right but he said we
should call it bird Laura called burglar
which is my gosh that's down home right
now now if you're Hillsdale College you
know you might have a class in
ornithology you'll never a class in bird
lore at Hillsdale but it sounds so much
more high etoy to you say ornithology
yeah well one of the things the Ango by
the end it says hey shut your mouth and
use n go please right that's my first
poems like don't say an go grab you gunk
amongst us that's dumb so 100% we can
count on my not saying that right
there's probably three people in the
room who could sit properly right and
they've been prank there's one my wife
but you make her yeah family business
yeah no um she no not her sorry thank
you I love you the the Ango poem starts
with hey be quiet
use normal use $1.00 words right but
that's not the whole story because if
you just leave it there and it's all
just common bird law or folk wisdom
right then you actually don't have
people that are capable of going all the
way down the rabbit hole into the
difficulties of the search for wisdom
right you have to you have to have
ornithologists right because science is
good and knowledge is good see but you
also have to be able to the the the the
good mother which was what Chaucer
called it that poetry teaches to switch
modes to be in a very highfalutin mode
like you can do that but then you can
also like talk and be normal right and
not sound like a weirdo right so that
ability to switch modes right and to be
able to yeah I can do angle grab you
gunk along sisyphic got to write for
certain things right in the right place
at the right time but I also know how to
switch modes Machiavelli talks about
this all the time like new modes and
orders well it's way older than
Machiavelli like this is back Ciceronian
rhetoric the liberal arts tradition of
being modal like being able to speak in
different ways it's a fundamental task
that poetry teaches and I'm trying to
bring it back we're getting the band
back together you know so we're gonna
move to the audience participation phase
in just a moment but a couple questions
about what you do in your normal life
you're a teacher at the Heights
what is the heights what do you teach so
at the heights on the director of the
Robert Jackson Scholars Program for the
seniors which is a class they do a 30 to
40 page research thesis and then defend
it for an hour before a semi hostile
panel with questions from the public
that sounds like fun
yeah that's great I mean it for you it
is
actually I get to learn a lot because I
have to go on all these new research
programs in the 90s history of Western
thought it's of course I helped design
they sort of Plato to NATO sort of
journey through great book and then I
also teach us history and then I teach
an American Lit class where we also book
end and cheat with we do the Odyssey at
the end for reasons I won't explain here
but it's an awesome book and then we do
a Shakespeare play at the beginning so a
lot of different humanities courses and
you also teach here at the Kirby Center
so what is your connection to Hillsdale
College what do you do with the college
so we're some teaching fellow I work
with under and for Matt Spalding here
and then I I teach the Washington
Hillsdale internship program so students
come from Hillsdale undergrads come and
they have internships here and I teach a
literature course and then i also run
seminars for young professionals on
philosophy rhetoric poetry these sorts
of liberal arts we do Shakespeare plays
we do
Cicero's on friendship and practicing
the art of friendship and then I also
help out with the coffee with the
classics program Hillsdale has for
Capitol Hill staffers in the Capitol
building she's like always teaching yeah
always yeah it's like those always
reppin you know those those basketball
shoes she's always so he's teaching abt
oh yeah teaching exactly say say say who
you are and ask your question hi I'm Tim
Carney I'm a heights dead I I read the
book I loved it and I loved the sort of
Strauss II and multi-level thing that
you're doing there because one of the
things when you have a lot of kids is
you realize this world
this world isn't built for people to
show up with kids of varying different
levels of ability even half the swimming
pools don't let you have you know
somebody in the kiddie pool and someone
in the big pool this book appealed to
all my kids on different levels but
sometimes it was I needed somebody at
the next level like you know you or
somebody with Yakka I wasn't at the
highest level and particularly this guy
here the the couple the pink and the
blue but there was a lot of action and
imagery going on in that I had some
hints as to what was going on can you
just talk about the tankless the letter
T pole is in in one sense it's
essentially about family life in general
and the incredible struggles that
parents have to raise children and I
don't mind revealing at least one of
many many stupid puns throughout this
book this tankless task will be the road
right it's the thankless task of
parenting and my hope is that parents
read it and just laugh out loud you know
these two these three or these two
limbless parents that they have to climb
a mountain in order to have a family and
it's actually quite difficult to raise a
family
I recommend it but it's an effort but
they don't have any lives and the ball
has to literally climb entire
mountain range from the sea without any
arms or legs and the mother tankless has
to dig a den without any arms and legs
and limbless does so with her face
horrible difficult thing which you know
in a certain sense you know me
empathizing with my my wife's travails
and raising our children but you're
never home right your teacher teaching
other people all the time yeah but just
an homage for parents to see you know
hey it's hard I know it's hard you know
stick with it it's very difficult but
it's our way you know there isn't
another way raising children in effort
is the way and and here it is Rheda
picked it for you as natural as can be
so buck up Tim Carney right and keep
being a dad okay got it
another question um hi mr. mean thank
you so you said you teach the Odyssey
and you're talking about the need for
poetry in our society to kind of have a
bit of a rebirth so I'm wondering what
you think of something like Emily
Wilson's recent translation of the
Odyssey that is kind of in more updated
modern language do you think that's like
a step in the right direction for the
sort of thing or Emily Wilson who was on
the great books podcast this summer
talking about the artists I almost want
to let him answer the question I'm
reading it now to decide whether
actually it'll be the Edition for that
we do this spring I you know so I don't
want it I don't want to make a pre pre
judgment about the work but the I tend
to use Fitzgerald because it translates
the line in a line of poetry so you
actually get access into the Greek death
Ramba
nature of the poem it's a fancy $10 word
the the poet what he does in a line is
translated there in that line so you can
make more judgments about what the
poetry is doing in translation so I tend
to like those kinds of more strict
lyrically rigid poetry because I really
like being able to get involved in the
mind of the poet and what they're
sharing with me and the more access I
have to their sort of their choices
blini Asian is really important to me
exactly I actually I am NOT gonna let
you get out of this room without explain
why I teach the Odyssey in American Lit
Homer was Greek give us your give us
your elevator pitch for how you how you
justify that yeah so mr. Bean's mildly
amusing I'm doing to do it indirectly
mister means mildly amusing mythical
mammals I was told by a number of people
don't do that do not have a long hard to
say title people will hate you for it
they said well I don't care it's gonna
be fun and it's gonna be Willie and it's
gonna add my name in it because I wanted
to be something friendly even if it
means it's a little imperfect I like
that the English tradition the
Anglophone tradition the American
tradition has always been some
imperfections right it's not Versailles
the the orange tree isn't cut like a
cube like on the continent it's a little
wooly in our Gardens right I like a
curriculum it's not perfectly thematic
even Homer nods right one simply right
yeah well that's an allusion to a piece
of literature
to Jesus Laurie actually you're right
yeah yeah so so that's my my Jade's
trick is shakes but Shakespeare would
say but the other reason is it's a
fundamental text beneath the moby-dick
so you're not gonna read Moby Dick very
fruitfully which they do the next year
so it's kind of preparation for that but
also it's it's that is the that is the
poem of self-government right it's all
about speech acts and being shrewd and
having a good wit and realizing when
someone's blowing smoke right and
Odysseus the liar or the Odysseus the
man in many turns right that's actually
an incredible education and citizenship
and so my my US history and literature
core class that's merged together does a
lot of primary sources we do an American
narrative but we also pick literature
that's designed to shape citizens to
have the kind of wit to see a hawk from
a handsaw a tyrant from a just ruler and
that's in short supply so I think the
Odyssey does a good job there another
question thank you my name is Todd
Wiggins and I appreciate your I want to
talk about your illustrations because
there are striking and well composed and
obviously beautifully executed so may I
ask you if at all who are the influences
I think of rockwell only because that's
a classic portraiture artists that has
great context in history and his
conceptions but I'd like to ask you if
there's anyone in particular
in the say recent past that you may have
been compared to yeah so I didn't do the
illustrations that I almost don't want
to answer for John because John will
just go but but I can I can give you
this that the Boston School and a lot of
the realist impressionist painters this
school is somewhat new in that it tries
to take the Impressionists which I you
know
name names but and the realists and put
them together into so that's one in
terms of the artistic craft of John
studied John folly but within each of
the paintings we try to have different
artistic quotes and different ones quote
different differently this is actually a
that one there too coal vein oh the
letter C which is that poem and this
painting are about the sort of the the
pedigree of the Greek tradition and the
greco-roman tradition of poetry but
that's what she's based upon an
impressionist painting called Mount
Helicon which is if you don't know a
mount Helicon is it's actually the
birthplace of the muses has seen writes
about and the muses are complicated
right there the their the nine daughters
of Zeus and memory right so God and your
own mind mixing together inspiration but
they also say we lie but we tell truth
when we want right so one of the things
poetry does is its images that can be
deceptive but actually trains you to
think about a world that doesn't always
give you the truth right away all right
you have to think carefully and
prudently about what's in front of you
so we chose that painting as as a
referent because it's thematically
helpful for the depth of boom so we try
to do that with with the paintings
throughout we had a question back I
think if someone still has it this will
be our last question one more question
thank you Matt how are you so I you you
mentioned just now that all of the
mammals are combinations except for one
and I'm gonna guess in a book like this
this is that's not happenstance so
what's the mammal that's not a
combination and and why isn't he or she
it's right there it's actually the lucky
test the vaquita
is actually an endangered species in the
Gulf of Cortes Gulf of Mexico by south
of California in Mexico there's only
probably about 12 of them
and it's the smallest of all the
cetaceans the babies the baby whales
their babies are the size of a loaf of
bread they're people calm sea pandas
they're impossibly cute but they're
probably gonna die that's so sad it is
yeah they sound adorable but that's not
a mythical mammal that will be soon mmm
I really do but but I put it in there
for two reasons one as a final challenge
because if you pay attention you read
the glossary and you come to understand
what the vaquita is and if you listen to
the lullaby which is a we produced a
beautiful version that's gonna go in the
audio book but I actually in the book
it's an illustrated score of the song
that I wrote because I wanted people to
see song and poetry is bound together
which i think is another important thing
that needs to be rediscovered but but
it's a very sad plaintive little lullaby
that actually wrote while nursing a sick
child when I was supposed to be writing
a completely different poem about this
but then I had to shift gears then two
days of a sick kid so I couldn't I
couldn't write because my wife was but
but it's also thematically the book is
like there's a challenge of sadness I
mentioned it a couple times that is a
challenge of sadness it's things that
get lost due to human error that can't
be brought back gone forever an extinct
species is a perfect example and it's
about mammals so it's a good one that's
actually a serious thing like hey you
screw something up and you can't get it
back it's gone forever well how do you
handle that problem right so implicitly
the vaquita works on a number of levels
for the book and it's it is a beautiful
creature and we're donating a small
portion of proceeds to help recovery
efforts but I don't know if you know it
might be for a to help some other
endangered species or something how can
they not buy the book now you'll help
save the what is it called the vaquita
you'll help save the vaquita if you if
you buy the book and
and it is it is worth noting that you
know the conservative side of things
oftentimes doesn't talk about ecology
and the environment very much but it is
something that most of us actually care
about and that we have a common ground
with people outside of our group that
shares everything in common are a lot
more in common and so it's always good
to sort of remind people of the things
we have in common with those outside our
group to try to knit things back
together which is good to find common
ground
okay Matt Mian thank you very much
[Applause]